Ніхто не скаже, що в той момент відчували пасажири рейсу MH17,
але відомо, як це було: вибух ракети,
миттєва смерть пасажирів перших рядів та екіпажу, майже миттєва - решти пасажирів.
І ось так все починалося у російських ЗМІ:
"Ополченцы сообщают, что им удалось сбить еще один транспорт украинских ВВС..."
Вже потім з'ясувалося, що цей чорний дим - від катастрофи насправді пасажирського авіалайнера,
в якому перебувало майже 300 людей з 17-ти країн світу.
Через три роки після тих подій слідство вже багато що знає.
Нідерландська рада з безпеки з'ясувала технічний бік справи: літак збив не український винищувач,
а ракета, випущена з комплексу "Бук".
Після неї Об'єднана слідча група з представників Нідерландів, Австралії, Малайзії, Бельгії та України підтвердила:
літак над Донбасом збили ракетою російського виробництва "Бук", випущеною з території, підконтрольної проросійським сепаратистам.
В якості доказів надали уламки лайнера, рештки ракети, фото російської установки "Бук" в районі катастрофи
та телефонні розмови сепарастистів з російськими військовими,
які привезли установку в район селища Первомайське на Донеччині, а згодом - швидко її звідти вивезли.
Перед третьою річницею катастрофи MH17 вирішили, що суд відбудеться у Нідерландах.
Адже варіант з Міжнародним судом ООН ветувала Росія, а створювати новий міжнародний суд
- складно, дорого і головне - довго. Об'єднана слідча група встановила коло зі ста підозрюваних,
проте імен не називає. А от незалежні розслідувальні групи Bellingcat та Correctiv
вже наводять імена причетних до пуску ракети - як сепаратистів, так і російських військових.
Шанси на те, що Росія видасть їх Гаазі - мінімальні. Україна ж підписала угоду з Нідерландами
про повну правову співпрацю. Згідно з якою підозрювані у причетності до катастрофи українці
постануть перед судом за допомогою відеозв’язку, бо Конституція України не дозволяє екстрадицію громадян.
Та коли розпочнеться процес - досі невідомо. І здійснення правосуддя
може виявитись ще складнішою справою, аніж збір доказів.